a rare sight in the rest of araucania
region some 30 indigenous maputo leaders
agreeing to meet the country's president
Gabriel boric to hear his proposals
solving the conflict in South Central
Chile
the region is under a state of emergency
patrolled by the Army and militarized
police
attacks by armed mapucha groups escalate
as they call for the return of their
ancestral lands
Al Jazeera was given exclusive access to
the meeting which at first was tense
outlined a plan to create a commission
with the participation of indigenous
leaders to determine how much land can
be returned to the mapuchis and by what
means
representing the Palencia Community
Maria Romero capil had a counter
proposal there is
the Chilean state must recognize its
crimes of genocide committed against the
mapuche people in the context of the
so-called pacification of the araucania
other countries that live in peace with
their indigenous people have had to
recognize these crimes and compensate
them in order to have peace
but there's another stumbling block to
dialogue the militarization of the
region
in an extensive interview with President
bodic I asked about his change of heart
on the issue you had said during in your
campaign that the first thing or one of
the first things you would do would be
to lift the the state of emergency and
it didn't work
yes exactly one of the things one has to
be able to do when you face certain
realities and you see that the things
you would like aren't working is to
change course we lifted the state of
emergency and we were obliged to
re-establish it in May because the
violence escalated potentially you had
once said that you thought it was
necessary to sit down with members of
these armed groups to have a dialogue
with them do you still believe that
I believe it's necessary to talk to all
those who are willing to have dialogue
you can't say I'm going to talk about
the conflict but not talk with all the
actors that are involved that would be
absurd those who are willing to talk
will be part of the debate we propose
so far the rebel groups say they're not
interested and those who are are making
demands the president bodage will
unlikely meet as long as the violence
continues
to see a Newman Al Jazeera Santiago